just i'm so proud
but uh yeah i mean it's for prague
though it's that negativity is that
wrong mindset of playing for a draw yeah
even if he played great moves even if it
was a draw
yeah eventually you will make one small
mistake and magnus loves that type of
thing white's night now has given itself
up
uh it cost that knight to get rid of
black's dangerous pawn
and magnus threatening checkmate again
in the corner
black knight just needs to find a safe
square and this one will be game over
okay a few more checks from
magnus he just he just blunted his
knight no way
uh he just thought he was threatening
checkmate in the corner of the board but
the white queen now defends against any
checks and look at his face he's still
laughing there he's had enough now has
he had enough is he a designer he's
resigned okay there comes a handshake oh
a polite handshake pregnant
wins the match against world champion
magnus carlson but it is
magnus who takes the win in the fdx
cryptocu